so frontier asked me to make something
for III this year more specifically they
asked me to make the Los Angeles
Convention Center in which it is held in
planet coaster which you're looking at
right now now you can see it passed by
in the e3 trailer for planet coaster and
you can also find a much better video
that puts the park in a much better
light probably on the planet coaster
channel on YouTube but just if you're
wondering how it was made and could go
for some extra planet coaster videos I
guess I did record some of the making of
this park and figured I would just throw
that together to make this quick video
on well how the park was made pretty
much so just a quick disclaimer I didn't
actually film making the exterior of the
building because that turned into a
terrible process of trial and error and
actually became really time-consuming
much more so than the indoor parts of
this park actually and wasn't really
that fit for a time-lapse especially
since I just wanted to do one video on
this so yeah that's just something to
keep in mind here but starting off I
basically already built the building
here and had the sort of basic shape of
it in mind already I just for time
constraints was going with the South
exhibit hall basically the Los Angeles
Convention Center is mainly divided into
two parts there's the south and the west
convention hall and just to make things
a bit easier here I figured I would go
with the South one since it is the
biggest one and the one that has by far
the most recognizable entrance
especially with that big glass facade at
the front of it and just seem best fit
for a indoor theme park in here I also
wanted to lay it out similarly to the
Rio convention hall like obviously there
are a couple of things to note about
this building since it's not completely
true to the nature of the Rio convention
hall part of the reason of course being
that there is a theme park inside of it
but I also changed the scale of a
building it's on a scale of one to one
point 2/3 which seems very awfully
specific but one of the issues that I
sort of came across was that the
increments of the front facade in real
life are 9 degrees while they're 15
degrees is like the lowest increment
that you can have in planet coaster and
still have it be real
which is why nine squares in planet
coaster would effectively be 15 squares
in real life so it is quite a bit
smaller than the real-time counterpoint
I also went with that idea since halfway
building an earlier version it turned
out to be way too big for the map it's
actually fit on and in hindsight this
well this much smaller scale works out a
bit better for making a small theme park
because I want to make a sort of
family-oriented theme park as well I
originally took a lot of inspiration
from lots of world in Korea which you
might want to look up if you're into
indoor theme park service theme parks in
general it's pretty famous it's the
biggest indoor theme park in the world
still is I believe but it's arguably
also the most beautiful one it's really
beautiful into a park so it's sort of my
first idea that I wanted to go to when I
wanted to make something indoor but a
later stage is actually figured
especially considering the size of this
thing
and the flat rights that we have at the
moment as well as just in general the
scenery pieces that we have the moment I
figured it would be best to go with
something like the park to Overland in
the Netherlands you might know it if
you're Dutch especially it's a pretty
underrated Park in the Netherlands which
started off as an indoor theme park
now it's much more and it's been
investing crazily but it has some really
like small children and family oriented
indoor halls and it's got just the right
amount of like being quite small and
just a modest theme park well at the
other hand just having some nice rides
and scenery that I figured it would be a
good inspiration for this kind of park
and so that's the sort of idea that I
went with and in that sort of spirit
much like the first hole into Overland I
wanted to have like one sort of main
attraction in the hall that you could
see like in the entire Hall which
intervlan is a small vakama junior
coaster and in this case I figured I
would make it a small zero junior
coaster for lack of a comas and that's
basically what I went with so that's
mainly going to be the centrepiece of
the park not just in the fact that the
ride more or less goes everywhere it's
also going to have like a pretty big
station that more or less sets the
theme for the rest of the park and fills
in a sort of central role that otherwise
a Disney Castle would have and there are
a couple of practical reasons for this
theme as well it's honestly Alpine is a
theme that I've done way too many times
before and kind of should probably avoid
at this time but it's also something I
can do pretty quickly and truth be told
this was made in a pretty short time
span especially considering that this
was a very unfortunate period because it
was right after my exams had ended and I
finally opened up some free time but
just before it had to be sent over to e3
which was kind of awkward and it just
felt like the most safe choice to go for
an Alpine because I can pretty much ring
that at this point even though it's
pretty uninspired though I'm still
really happy with how this station came
out especially considering that it's
more or less the central focus of the
park in general and it also really works
from the standpoint that this is a
pretty low hole considering the fact
that I did want to make the building of
the Convention Center true to scale
since I made the building in here quite
a bit smaller than the real-life
counterpart but still wanted to get the
dimensions more or less right the roof
or the ceiling I should say in this case
is pretty low so I couldn't really build
anything really high so that meant no
high flat rides no very tall
rollercoasters but also no big towers on
my buildings and really the only theme
that I figured would be quite reliable
for a somewhat small building but still
the building that would be the largest
within the theme park and have this sort
of central focus would be something that
has an Alpine theme it's also kind of
generic without being too generic like
it's still a theme but it's something
that isn't too unique or stands out too
much to be the entire theme of a theme
park I feel so yeah that's more is
pretty much my idea for it and in terms
of the style it is quite different from
the sort of grizzly Valley Alpine that
I've tried before which was pretty much
my first
singing around in Planet coasters so
definitely should show an improvement
over that like using some of the bricks
over here to make the roofs which looks
just a little bit better one of the
biggest things about this station I
think which I'm quite happy with is how
sort of playful the roof is I did want
to keep it to just the very simple gable
roofs here just because they're sort of
well I'll pines staple at this point and
just because I didn't want to go
overboard with towers or details
everywhere and just to make the entire
station design a bit more playful and
dynamic I wanted to stack a few
different roofs in like different
settings different heights and at
different parts of the station just to
make it look a bit more interesting from
the different angles from which you can
look at it while still making it pretty
simple of a building and I was actually
really happy with how the cornerstones
turned out on the side of that tower
there definitely something I want to
remember for future reference as well
it's a little bit light I guess compared
to the texture of the wall itself but
cornerstones like that have more or less
always been a favorite Alpine thing for
me especially since rollercoaster tycoon
3 had them with Alpine's with the alpine
sets of shyguy and two something I
wanted to get in here as well and just
to make it still a bit fancy and have a
nice little Tower right in front of the
entrance so you at least have like a
tall structure in front of the entrance
as tall as I could get it in this hole
at least I wanted to get a small spire
which almost touches the ceiling as you
might be able to tell actually by the
blue lines which I haven't actually
talked about the blue lines in the sky
at the moment a [ __ ] basically my
markers for how high the ceiling is
gonna be which is why I wanted to have
them there though I am still gonna add
like some girders underneath the ceiling
to be able to realistically support it
so it's not an entirely realistic
representation of how high the ceiling
is gonna be but it's more or less a good
clue to how high I could make these
buildings and like what's all the flat
rides could be that I could use
a spike in general and couple other
touches through this building is the
rest was pretty simple really just
windows and doors a little bit of wooden
framework but I didn't want to go
overboard with the framework in here
it's a pretty important staple of Alpine
buildings in general too but I was
pretty happy with having very simplistic
our wooden framework looked here but I
definitely didn't want to have some
flower boxes which at the moment you can
definitely build flower boxes out of
better things than what I've done here
especially the wooden brick it actually
works pretty well for it but it's just
something that I really felt the need to
get into this building since it's just
one of those things that is just so very
alpine and it just breathed this
atmosphere especially since this park is
gonna be somewhat simple and not going
to be anything really epic or massive or
incredibly detailed in that way I wanted
to create like a nice little atmosphere
without having to go into like
ridiculous budget and one of the nice
ways to always be able to do that is to
just add some planters and some window
boxes around the buildings now I wanted
to add this big path around the center
part of the bowler coaster and the plan
is more or less to within that path
avoid any kind of flat ride or anything
like that and keep it just to services
and the coaster itself and have the flat
rides and all that good stuff on the
outer rings or more or less outside of
this main sort of path and just have
this be know sort of the main area which
I could fail with the smaller things
that I could fill in here and leave the
outer area where there's just a little
bit more space open to be able to place
as many of the small and flat rides that
I can actually fit in this very low
ceiling in there and one idea actually
had over here which this was recorded I
think yeah this was recorded before
episode 5 6 & 7 of Boneshaker
was to make the picnic tables into one
building the picnic tables idea was deaf
of Devilfish idea on reddit or youtube
so massive credit goes out to him but it
works a little bit better if you save it
under one building just
by lowering one building piece into the
ground like a wall or a roof piece and
then use the 3d gizmo by pressing X to
put the scenery pieces together and you
can just save one picnic table us
building and basically copy that over
and use it throughout the park which is
pretty nice and that's basically what I
wanted to do around here with the
benches and the planters and anything
else that I could just easily copy
around as well it's kind of funny
because the scenery item is actually the
driftwood plank or the two three four
wood planks but most of the users I've
seen for it or actually not driftwood
how its kind of strange that we have to
read through it anyway since we don't
actually have water yet I guess it could
be used on beaches but not with any
water that is but they're actually
incredibly used for one of the best
pieces I think in the game actually
since they have this really good texture
definitely a sort of really blank look
to them and you can build just about
anything you really want out of them
especially these smaller part items like
window boxes flower boxes planters
benches picnic tables and they work
pretty well for a wooden framework and
even roofs as well definitely one of my
favorite pieces at the moment anyway
that's a bit of topic I wanted to finish
the roller coaster just pretty quickly
it is a zero coaster but it's more or
less inspired by the Kakuma junior
coasters I am still not sure why I like
the coma it might just be the fact that
I'm Dutch but it's a pretty big
inspiration in this case now all of the
rides in this park are going to be very
family oriented except for the zipper
which I just placed I guess which is the
one exception one of the reasons of
course why I barely placed any thrill
rides is the fact that the ceiling is
pretty low and doesn't actually allow
for many of the thrill rides that we
have in the game at the moment but I
guess another reason would just be that
you know this is very small Park it's
kind of inspired by toverland
and I wanted to keep that sort of family
sort of approach to the park especially
since it's so small same goes for toggle
on when it just opened it also opened
with just one hole with one roller
coaster and some family rides it's
not too unrealistic actually and this
building somehow fits the well the theme
park having inside of it so maybe if
it's done being a convention center it
could be turned into it but yeah that's
why i realistically felt i wanted to go
with this sort of well these flat rights
which are pretty family oriented and
having a family coaster or kiddie
coaster you might even say as a
centerpiece of the park itself and what
I also did want to do there which I'll
probably get to yeah I'll get to later
in this video is actually cover up the
walls which is something that I did
struggle with quite a bit all the time
because there is no way to really get
fancy walls I could not get any glass
into Latin light and because that's just
not how many Convention Center is built
and pretty much the issue here is that
if it's nice it's a bit too dark but if
it's they there's an awkward lighting
thing going on we're pretty much the
entire park is casting a shadow but it
still lets some of the sunlight in which
is a bit awkward but nothing I could
really avoid but that made it kind of
awkward to make the insides actually
somewhat realistic and resembling a
real-life theme park coming back to the
planters actually that I just placed a
little bit ago that I completely skipped
over I wanted to get quite a good amount
of planters with trees in here basically
because I want to avoid cutting trees
anywhere except for the planters in
general basically because it is an
indoor theme park
and I don't start having forests or
anything like that in the theme park I
do have quite a few patches of grass in
there which is already pushing it quite
a bit but I felt that we just make it a
little bit nicer to look at than just
having concrete everywhere which is
something that I wish I could have
actually done but it's pretty much
impossible the roof tiles have these
things sticking out on the side so you
can't really use those to get any kind
of texture in so the thing that I ended
up using for the crown textures to make
it look a little bit more like it's
actually an indoor theme park and not an
indoor forest is to use this sand as a
sort of concrete texture but it's not
quite that's convincing but yeah I
wanted to most
we use planters and many many window
boxes and or I should say flower boxes
to get some foliage in here while not
making it too unrealistic for an indoor
theme park
well at the same time giving it a bit of
atmosphere as well and over here is
pretty much one pretty big space which I
figured I could make a little path into
here because it seemed like too small of
a space to really get another flat ridin
but then again it's too large of a space
to do nothing with especially in an
indoor theme park we're in this very
small hole I didn't want to make the
most out of this haunt use pretty much
every inch of the building that I had
without making it look too cramped and
felt this was a pretty good way to get
that in there have a small path lead
there with just a few benches in the
future
and make it a little back area in that
kind of way and since I have a food
store and I have toilets I don't have
any head shops but I did miss one thing
which is pretty important which is a
drink store I figured it would be nice
to have a little cosmic cow over here so
that's what I decided to go with it's
also pretty simple building a little
Alpine inspired building I wanted to
dress it up like a stall much like a
rollercoaster [ __ ] install because even
though I'm not a huge fan of that this
is sort of an indoor theme park so
trying to create the classic theme park
idea while it's already a building
within a building so just figured if I
would have a standalone building within
this building a nice little store for
drinks could work quite well over there
and just make sure that the area around
it
is good enough to just take a seat
somewhere and sit about and have your
cosmic cow milkshake
that kind of idea generally which is
also where I decided I would make this
simple bench and place that along the
park and just make sure that there are
some areas where people can sit
especially since this is a theme park
I'm placing many benches over here just
so people can sit just about everywhere
the only thing that is missing still is
a little bin which is still something I
might want to get it back into the
future I it is pretty possible to make a
little bit out of the driftwood blind
and just copy that around it's not that
convincing but it's better than nothing
so definitely something I wanna mess
around with in the future as well there
are so many things you can actually do
with the current scenery pieces to make
your own kind of path elements even
though there aren't any more path
elements in the game as of yet so
there's definitely a lot to still mess
with that and hopefully at least this
gives you some ideas and just because
these trees are really handy the thing I
like about tsipras's is that they're
really simple similar to poplars and I'm
pretty much using them as poplars in
this case which are really often used
tree because they probe really quickly
they're pretty narrow and just pretty
good because you can place trees and
make things look a little bit more
inviting and lit more a little bit more
atmospheric but there's still quite
small and narrow so they don't block the
view completely so you can have some
trees and plants in there without making
the park looked like a forest which is
basically exactly what I wanted in this
case now because I didn't really like
staring that's an ugly white border
there I figured it would be nice to at
least have a little scenery like border
alongside the edge of the park and add a
bit of rocks here in there too well here
and there pretty much everywhere so he
may get a sort of Rocky Mountain like
little area alongside the side here and
dressed it up a little bit as well so it
doesn't look like it's a beach anymore
which it kind of does at the moment and
actually add some stuff alongside the
rocks as well just to make things a bit
more inviting I do have to say and I
just don't you know not be critical of
myself or the entire III thing in
general this was incredibly rushed in
the end and you might have probably been
able to tell I know for a fact that some
people have been able to tell it was
definitely quite rushed hence why this
is only the South's exhibit [ __ ] and I
didn't have the West exhibit hall in it
which I kind of hoped would be possible
in the end but didn't really have time
to do so and yeah so there were
definitely many compromises that were
made just for time constraints like
going with these quite simple theme and
things like that and in a perfect world
I would
kind of hoped to see some buildings
alongside the side of the walls like
what you commonly see in the theme parks
is that you don't really have actual
buildings but just like decorative
buildings alongside the walls or painted
buildings or helped sometimes even
constructed buildings that really
protrude from the wall on the side of
the park to kind of make that border not
so much something that just encloses the
park but something that's really
incorporated into the scenery and that's
something which I kind of missed in this
case and definitely something which you
might want to try if you're making an
indoor theme park and something which I
would have definitely improved on as
well if I would look back at this park
and have more time to work on it again
now the rest of this is just filling up
the park with more Rock work to make
sure that there aren't any really empty
spaces especially since it is an indoor
theme park
I didn't want to be left with any spaces
that were you left unused because you
realistically don't really see it you
don't have that much space left in an
indoor theme park with the pretty small
holes that they're built in so not
making use of a certain space is kind of
waste and if you still have some empty
space just place a little scenery item
in there and just incorporate it and
bits into the scenery and the theming of
the entire hall so that's why I pretty
much figured I would do with this little
corner over here to the left of which it
is pretty much just the entrance which
is a little bit of theming
I didn't really figure of any other way
to make it like work without not
incorporating it into the theme of the
park so I ended up just going with a
pretty generic entrance for the ticket
booths there but I'm still pretty happy
with how that came out and the rest of
it
is also pretty much just putting barrels
everywhere because you can always just
spam barrels if you have no idea what
else to really do in the end and I also
just wanted to do some quick fixing up
of the coaster smoothy smooth there
which always worked really well
I do recommend not doing it too much
because it might change your layout
especially if you have some really tight
curves but in general you can make
layouts pretty smooth if you just go
over them a couple of times with the
smooth tool really depends on how
not smooth or smooth a section is when
it comes to how much you have to smooth
it out but it always worked pretty well
anyway this is a final overview of where
the park looks like in its finished
States from above which is a shot that I
can offer which the planet coaster video
does not actually offer and yeah this is
basically what it looks like and how its
laid out so thank you guys for watching
I hope you guys at least learned some
stuff from this and if you guys still
have some feedback or suggestions that's
always cool as well anyway thanks for
watching and bye